[Musique]
laissez le tranquille
c'est un monde très dur
et il le devient sans cesse un peu plus
le monde ne changera pas c'est toi qui
doit changer
il s'est passé un truc incroyable
tu vas voir ce que j'ai trouvé quelque
chose est écrit sur la garde regardant
google traduction
ça veut dire ep d'arthur excalibur
l'épée dans la pierre alexander est
violent
c'est toi qui as sortir et p2 croyons
court un danger mortel
il reste quatre jours jusqu'à l'équipe
solaire alors morgan entrera dans le
monde des vivants et je suis censé la
stopper
c'est n'importe quoi j'ai 12 ans
je croyais de merlin est un vieil homme
tu as l'air d'avoir saison une
couverture ingénieuse pour te surveiller
incognito
tu devras rassembler une équipe de
chevalier ce d'arthur se réunissaient
autour d'une table ronde pour qu'ils
soient tous égaux et regardez vite
benders les rabats de la table vous
voyez alors toi t'es trop geek c'est le
destin
à nous cinq on n'aura pas la moindre
chance il faut lever une armée qui veut
se joindre à nous quelle humiliation
ceux ci remplacera les cours aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
effectif hormis kayes
c'est la pire chose et la meilleure
c'est terrible et la plus géniale qui me
soit jamais arrivée
oui
ou est ce que tu as appris à conduire
mario kart maman ne fit pas d'accord
dame du lac
veuillez rendre xcalibur